We're going to
take a look at how
point of view and composition
are very clearly connected.
But, before we show
the connections,
we have to sort of
define, visually define,
what I mean by point
of view, for example.
So, take a look at
these four images.
Now, it doesn't look
it, but these images
are of the identical
sample, just
simply taken with four
different points of view.
There, it's true that I also
changed the background on them,
but, generally, what I
did was I moved the sample
around or the camera, and we
get four really completely
different-looking visual ideas
of what this stuff was about.
Which one is right,
I'm not sure there
is a right in any of this.
That's one of the fun things
about this kind of work:
There are no hard, fast
rules that we have to follow.
But I wanted, to give
you, this example
to show you that just by
simply changing the angle or-of
your camera, or moving
your material around,
you see different things.
Again, we're learning
to see in this course.
So, in this situation, I
wanted to show the fabrication
of this particular
pyramid, sort of telling
a story in a particular image.
But for now, just
take a real good look
at this pyramid that was
made with this wafer that
was imprinted with a pattern.
And, I felt that this
was not quite right
because there was a
little ambiguity in where
the pyramid's point is.
It's a little too close
to the curve of the wafer.
So by simply raising the
camera ever so slightly,
we get a nice and clean
line without ... well,
let's continue calling it
ambiguity for the time being.
Here is an example where, for
this particular device (it's
a micro rotor) I shot
it from above because I
was using a stereo microscope.
I had just gotten this
brand new piece of equipment
that I had to use of course
because it's brand new!
And, from that point of
view, very unfortunately,
you see all kinds of
dust and yuck, which
I could not get rid
of because I don't
have control over the light.
So, I simply changed back
to my camera and my 105 lens
with a different
point of view which
gave me a much cleaner image.
Many times, we get stuck
on a particular approach
to looking at things, let's
say, directly from above
and it doesn't necessarily
give the best image.
Here's an example where,
this is a PDMS that's been
etched with a grading on it.
And I took it with
this particular view.
And just by simply
changing the PDMS
to a slightly
different position,
we get a different
point of view.
Let's go back and
forth on this and see.
It's kind of fun
to do this anyway,
but you'll notice
that you really see.
This one has a better approach
to looking at the refraction
but, at the same
time, you notice
when we-I did that, the shadow
is changing in its position.
Again, this is encouraging
you to understand
that when you change your
point of view, of course
you're also changing
your composition,
and they are very
much intertwined,
which we'll see more later on.
In this situation,
I had a petri dish,
with various gels that
had different colors.
(Let's just leave it with
that at the time being) This
was my primary,
initial point of view,
and I thought it
was kind of boring.
And so the point of view was
a little tighter in that I
chose to get the camera closer.
And I also included
different kinds
of gels: In this
situation, larger ones.
Uh, it is a different
point of view
in terms of your selection
of what it is that you
are going to be showing.
So these are not
very deep changes,
but enough to make very,
very different images.
As for example, this one which
is a glass wafer that's been
etched so that they're
creating channels
on the wafer from
this point of view.
And here is another
point of view
where I'm not showing
the whole thing.
And maybe we don't have to show
the whole thing all the time.
Maybe we can show
the work by something
that is, in my opinion, a more
interesting in composition
in a different point of view.
HERE, A SMALL CHANGE: Take
a look at both of these
and I hope you see
that in the first one,
it was a bit of a sloppy
point of view in the sense
that I'm showing labels.
That really is not
something of value.
And so by simply moving the
camera slightly and then
focusing a little closer,
it's a cleaner point of view.
Again, this is also
about composition,
but, they are very
much connected.
Here is this researcher's
point of view
where he decided to show the
flexibility of this material
and include hands, which
is a very good idea when
you want to show scale.
For me, I've decided to
be a little more playful
and just playing more
around the flexibility
and showing the shadows of it.
And we did get a cover of
a journal, which is nice.
A whole different point of view,
same material, both are good.
You know there's not, again,
not one is better than the other
necessarily.
I decided to dig out from the
depths of my slide collection
when I was an
architectural photographer
to show you a difference
that does somewhat inform us,
in this course.
Here's a beautiful
space in California
designed by Isamu Noguchi.
This is the first
image that I made.
And here is the second
And let's go back and forth
a little on this as well.
And you see in
this second image,
I decided to have
the camera point
slightly upward and
changing the point of view
so that we see a slant of sky.
I think this is a better image.
I think it's more interesting.
But I also think that
it allows the viewer
to sort of participate
more in the image.
That is to kind of
go along, upward
and be part of paying
attention to what
is going on with the sky.
I think showing the edges and
the connection between the edge
of something beyond is an
interesting view of how to show
things as I did here ' back
to our world ' when I needed
to show bubbles, uh,
for a book that we did.
I decided to keep the
edge of the plate showing
and show the background.
It is a point of view that
I felt sort of worked.
And here is another point of
view with the same material.
Which is better?
I'd be interested to
hear your opinions.
Here is a device with
the researcher's point
of view of it.
And this is my point of
view where I ' first of all,
I did get it in focus [LAUGHS]
but since we're talking about
point of view, I'll stay with
that, at that, I'll try to.
And all I did was I put it on a
white background (which, we'll
get to backgrounds
later as well),
and I just slanted the device
and the camera's point of view,
and I think it's a much
more successful picture.
And finally, in
this situation, when
you do have a device that
is almost, pretty much
symmetrical, if you're going to
take a photograph, from above,
you just better make sure that
you make the image symmetrical
as well.
Take a look at this
first one again.
And, you know
there's nothing worse
than an almost okay image.
If it were really
really off symmetry,
that would work better than
just a tad off symmetry.
So, my suggestion
is to, if you do
decide to make a
symmetrical-like image, to just
make sure it is a
symmetrical point of view.